yeah what do you think of that man was
that wade in the water yes
Wow what the [ __ ] you say wade in the
water yes that's what it is
you look very nice today thank was your
hair I came from a career what premieres
called the Sun on AMC I saw Pierce
Bronson I rubbed his shoulder yo is that
over there at the ArcLight our client
Taylor the one that bill that could
plays my girl of the song yeah [ __ ] that
[ __ ] it because we have a [ __ ] guest
Oh about that no mister all right you
[ __ ] fancy ass Asian dude I can't
okay you guys um I I really believe that
this is the best guests we've had on TV
a lot of expectations no dude I'm
telling you right now dude it's like you
know you learn you meet people you know
you you connect you work you you can you
connect on a spiritual level you know
what I mean and uh years ago I was on a
sketch show called MADtv and 15 Mexicans
watched it nice yeah yeah and they loved
it they loved it and I met a young man
while I was on that show who got cast by
the name of Jordan Peele and he's with
us right now how about a round of
applause so what is this guy right here
all right we are we're good we are I
would call us very very good friend yes
I would say that dude because we worked
for five years together yeah and we we
know in this the work part but we had
adventures brawl we had adventures yeah
we had a bond of of disgust for what we
were doing we had we had a fear of how
it was coming off yeah and we banded
together yeah an anger almost anger
definitely yeah you just I just want to
call it you said Pierce Bronson yeah
that's a that's
absolutely not as that's not right brah
Brosnan Brosnan yeah yeah how do you say
it Bronson Bronson you [ __ ] [ __ ]
bro noticin yeah perfect strangers
didn't didn't start Brosnan Pinchot but
can I just say that he should have
changed his name why close to Pierce
Bronson yeah Brosnan whatever see what
I'm saying it's like you got it's like
if somebody said like I started and
there's already a Bobby lolei yeah Rocky
that's Balki that's Balki yeah and
that'd be like all my change it to
Hirohito or whatever it might be you
know Denzel Washington that is a perfect
like that's a perfect yeah college
football name we go way back we go way
back
a lot of lot of adventure a lot of
adventures we were there in Houston when
what's-his-name George st. Pierre lost
Matt Serra oh because we were doing we
were hired by the UFC only one time to
do commentary that's right right how
much oh we did some sort of like brought
we interviewed people or something yeah
I don't remember did so what was it like
red carpet style we were like talking
something like that yeah it was that was
a fluke though GSP should have never
lost that fight good it came back and
destroyed Matt Serra what can I show you
this he did lose that's a fact and it
wasn't was not the best fight either I
remember I remember feeling like being
there in person was not not as good at
right we actually escorted into the
Octagon at one point before the thing we
got to walk around
what the way I want to get to the bottom
of what it was because it was one of
these things where we were on yeah we
were on MADtv so it was like we were you
know we basically called somebody but
we're invited when MADtv is invited to
do anything we show up on time and we're
like [ __ ] anything but being at
Hollywood Center studios we're doing did
you have you had MADtv people on this
show before no yeah you're the first it
was I don't know how do you feel about
was it was it a fun time well I was on
there way longer than you you left I was
there with Keegan a couple years
remember uh-huh and told you the last
two years or it was awful it was getting
grim it was grim because we had to move
and then they cut the budget half yeah
you know me and then we had these young
kids that came up like Johnny Sanchez
and Matt Braunger and kids Johnny
Sanchez is you know of course much older
than I am
[Music]
yeah he was 80
he was like 75 years old but what I
meant by in career-wise Yeah right
use a vet is a vet yeah how many bad but
yeah but the us being just kind of like
always complaining on stuff yeah yeah
yeah no advertisement I mean imagine
this you have Ike Barinholtz right you
have key and Peele
you got me you got you got you got any
weird you Michael McDonald Aries Spears
yeah well he's a very talented guy given
I crush it but I did I know but I did
I've talked about in this podcast I I
talked about him a called Tom's on radio
how mingi mean he was toward me at times
and what doing the [ __ ] mad tv
reunion he was there which by the way I
saw I saw
justyou're and Ike sketch and it was
great when I was living in the [ __ ]
thing
weird of [ __ ] and he got yo man can I
talk to you I go yeah he goes I sat next
to areas and he had it [ __ ] queued up
the radio interview from like Seattle
from six years ago why'd you say this
and he plays with one of me and I just
started laughing yeah there's no there's
no real consequences for you anything
well I get in trouble yeah a lot by who
I get in trouble by my my agents will
say stuff my manager will say stuff and
you know I've had some really horrific
you know show business tales that you
don't know about you know they're half
right and things that I [ __ ] up and
I've had to answer to all those things
it's interesting because comedic Lee
speaking you can get away with anything
true and that's what's really important
and mine is from II think as a friend
yes I mean I did that Comedy Central
thing and I do it naked my dick was out
and I can do things like that and but
the thing is is that's me I'm not doing
anything but me
[Music]